love
me
[Music]
so there are a lot of different ways to
enter the electric car market with your
first try from the established
manufacturers and from the startups so
like Ford's first mainstream EV was a
sedan and then Tesla's first one was
actually a sports car but then rivian's
first one was a pickup truck and so
that's why I find these so interesting
so I've already started to have a lot of
fun with these different high-tech cars
over on the new autofocus Channel shot
exclusively on smartphones link with a
like button of course but that is why
Lucid has been so interesting to me
because it seems to me that their
strategy at least from the outside
looking in is to just one-up Tesla at
everything that they possibly can
so okay this is Tesla's Flagship the
model S and this is lucid's air Grand
Tour
I'm a capera but if you just listen to
the basics on paper right the Lucid has
much much more range 446 miles on a
single charge from this air GT
performance it has faster charging 350
kilowatts Max it has a thousand plus
horsepower it's got stickier tires it's
more luxurious inside
got my attention
[Music]
so okay Tesla's Interiors were never
really anything to write home about but
I can say that this is a they did a
really good job this interior from Lucid
one UPS pretty much everything about
Tesla's interior there are better
materials everywhere with leather on
things that you touch the Alcantara
headliner there's a little bit of dry
wood trim and overall fit and finish of
everything in here is excellent it is a
quieter inside cabin both while sitting
and while driving and the seats are all
better with much more adjustment there's
multi-zone Heating and Cooling that
turns on and is effective super fast I
noticed and they even have several
massage programs which I never really
use in any car but every time I see it
you know you just get the feeling that
it's a little bit extra luxurious and
then the back seat experience is way
better so just as a reminder the
backseat of a Model S is pretty good
right I have a 6'3 driving position and
then another 6'3 passenger and my leg
room's all right headroom's pretty good
from the glass roof some decent quality
materials around me and then in the
middle I have a wireless charger a cup
holder and a screen to control the air
conditioning but this is lucid's
standard backseat first of all the door
now opens fully 90 degrees low-key a
really nice feature but then there's
just dramatically more legroom and space
because they opted for a normal trunk
instead of a hatchback so they've moved
in the same wheelbase as a Tesla this
seat way further backs now I have more
space I have dedicated HVAC controls
there's no wireless charger in the
middle but there is a cup holder and a
screen for the air conditioning and some
more storage but it's just much more
luxurious there is Storage in the back
of the seats there is access to the
trunk in between the two seats if you
take down that armrest there's also an
option in this car for you to take a
little bit of battery out of the floor
for a little bit more footwell room plus
you can't forget about those executive
seat options from the Prototype I tested
five whole years ago but wait there is
more I've been living this car for about
a week now and I there's just so many
things to it first of all the sound
system is actually incredible it has 21
speakers and they support you know
Spotify and things like that but also
tidal Hi-Fi in the UI and I swear I came
home from a drive and I just sat and
listened to the Dolby Atmos speakers for
a while and it just sounds so good
incredibly immersive there's also a
better steering wheel in here with
stocks and real buttons and I think
these knobs are a great idea they're
plastic but there's no creaking or give
to them and they work great for
selecting things or scrolling I like the
wheel there's also a more impressive
windshield that curves up over the
driver's head if you're into that with
some pretty sick ambient lighting strips
through the middle that glows softly at
night the tint in the roof is really
good it also just kind of acts like a
normal roof line but you can see things
through it and there are better HVAC
controls in this car thanks to real
buttons and that knob in the middle is
just a big volume knob but the center
console storage is really unique it
includes this this whole screen that
tilts back and reveals some hidden
storage space behind it where you could
keep some sunglasses or a mask or
whatever I don't know but probably most
impressively the Lucid has a much larger
powered opening and closing front that's
thanks to this wider shape and then the
smaller overall Motors in the front so
this is a massive and very useful front
trunk that I'm tempted to use way more
than the rear trunk itself and then
there is the software so it would be
really hard to one-up Tesla software
considering that's like the most
impressive part of their car but lucid's
gonna try and so they don't support
Android auto or apple carplay just like
Tesla they've built their own UI and
it's pretty bold and it has to be really
good I would say
it is yeah it's pretty good so you've
got two screens here this big one behind
the wheel with a touchscreen sensitive
area on either side and this second one
down in between the seats and the layout
here is smart they actually give you a
front opening instead of a trunk opening
which makes me want to use it more but
generally the UI in here is intuitive
and fairly fast not necessarily smooth
all the time as far as frame rates but
it's fast but this is by the way the 2.0
version of the software they had a bunch
of 1.x versions that were much slower
this version is more well laid out than
before and faster than before and
there's lots of useful features like
it's got this top down view in here for
parking that Tesla still for some reason
doesn't provide but it has this and a
360 surround version that shows the car
you're driving and the environment
around it from various angles and it
actually matches your spec here unlike
Porsches but you know there are
definitely some quirks too the weirdest
part to me is that you can't see music
and maps at the same time at least I
haven't been able to figure out how if I
want music up here I hit music but then
it also adds music on the bottom screen
but if I want want maps on the top
screen I hit Maps but then it switches
the bottom screen to Maps too so I want
music one place Maps the other place but
the nice thing is it's just software and
software is one of those things that can
improve over time and this is one of
those cars that's actually gotten
meaningful software updates over time
which is great to see but there's one
other thing that this car does really
well
and that
is Drive
[Music]
so something I've realized that is a
little underrated and doesn't get talked
about enough in cars is Cars that have
like multiple
personalities plural a personality is
nice but being able to switch between
being a sporty car and being a luxurious
chill car is nice so we can't ignore the
fact this is a big sedan so there are
three personalities Drive modes in the
settings here smooth Swift and Sprint so
smooth is great when you have passengers
you know it's got the gentlest
acceleration curve and regen the
lightest steering and the softest
suspension potholes aren't a huge
problem it still does have 21 inch
wheels so it's not the smoothest but I
find that the regen and one pedal
driving calibration on the Lucid is
great you almost never have to touch the
friction brakes if you don't want to I
do think if this had 19-inch Wheels it
would make a bigger difference to the
ride quality than just the suspension
setting here but this is about as good
as you can do with the 21s so as you get
sportier everything gets a little bit
lower a little bit heavier a little bit
firmer if you go all the way to Sprint
that is the car's lowest most responsive
and firmest setting so now I'm going to
feel all the bumps but that's what you
want when it's feeling more like a
sports car now it's not a sports car
right you can't exactly mask this car's
5 000 plus pounds of weight but it does
I will say it feels lighter than it
actually is it has this level of
mechanical grip it's not Arrow it's just
this the big tires and the mechanical
grip that gives you a confidence in an
all-wheel drive car this is really
confidence inspiring car to drive oh and
then it happens to have a thousand
horsepower so
yeah I will say though versatile car
legitimately three different
personalities for a car that costs this
much money I would want to be able to
decouple the different modes and things
that come with changing between Sprint
and Swift and smooth so like I for
example would really like to have the
Swift acceleration but the smoother
suspension but you can't decouple the
suspension from the acceleration it's
just three big buttons so it's cool if
you have a passenger you just hit the
smooth button then everything's smooth
and pillow like and luxurious and that's
pretty ideal I like that mode but yeah
if I want to play with a little bit for
this price I should be able to now
luckily that is a software thing so
there's a good chance that someday I
will be able to but I gotta say I am
very impressed with the way this car
drives and changes the way that it
drives this is the thing you always hear
when people review certain supercars
they're like wow it seems to be very
daily drivable I wouldn't expect that
from a car with all this horsepower and
this is the opposite it's a big heavy
luxurious smooth quiet sedan and when
you put it in Sprint mode and you really
play with it it kind of has that oh I
did not expect it to grip this well and
have all this traction and really fire
out of corners but it it does so when I
first drove this car the Lucid air
prototype like five years ago
that had this crazy executive seat
option which I don't think it should be
in any of them now but the point was
that's a car you'd want to be driven in
more than actually drive there's some
cars like that this one because they've
gotten all the other factors right in
the steering and handling and the
sportiness and the thousand horsepower I
can actually say this is a car I'd be
equally happy driving or being driven in
and that's an accomplishment but the
other thing I wanted to know after that
is okay they've showed the nice
prototype but when they ship it will it
actually get the 400 plus miles that
it's supposed to on a charge and now
that I've driven it with the range
estimates and the efficiency I can
actually say yes you are able to get 400
to 430 miles on a single charge on this
car's battery but you know what this car
is not perfect no car is perfect
obviously but I think for me actually
what it really comes down to is mostly
nitpicking because there's so many good
things about this car I just don't like
the way it looks that's just me maybe
this is a hot take I've seen some
comments from people saying like oh this
is the best looking Eevee out right now
they smoked everyone else in the
Aesthetics Department I disagree I like
the interior a lot I just don't like the
way the car looks from the outside
let me explain but I think what it comes
down to for me is the two-tone thing and
the shape of the back of the car the
two-tone thing this car has these huge
not Chrome but big silver pieces on it
giving it this two-tone look with the
body color I think they just tried to
copy my buck which is like you see a
two-tone Maybach and you know that
that's luxury but this one kind of ends
up looking like an older Lincoln if I'm
not mistaken I don't know there is a
stealth package that lets you like matte
black these out it's six thousand
dollars but then this is the back of the
car back here and because they decided
to go with the regular trunk and not a
hatchback you end up with much more rear
seat luxury and that's great but then
you also end up with this like bulbous
shape back here I get why they did it
they still have a trunk and aerodynamics
but now it doesn't look as good to me
the mouth of it when it opens looks kind
of funny because it's this huge piece
that has to open and then the opening
technically is a pretty good amount of
trunk space but I just went to Lowe's
the other day and bought a flower pot
don't ask why but I had a flower pot and
even that was hard to fit in this small
of an opening so the trunk suffers a
little bit and the Arrow does benefit
but that's how you end up with this back
of the car and that's why I think I'm
not the biggest fan of the aesthetic but
really overall I think Luca actually
does a really good job of one-upping
Tesla and a lot of those key ways that
people really think about and that
matters in an EV now unfortunately you
can probably see where this is going
that also means they are more expensive
across the lineup the whole thing this
Grand Touring spec that I'm in starts
starts at a hundred and fifty four
thousand dollars and then we all know
the flagship right now for Tesla is the
model S plaid they're actually coming
out with a Sapphire version of this car
not supposed to come out next year to
match the triple motor powertrain and
guess what it one-ups Tesla at
everything again it's faster zero to 60
faster zero to 100 faster in the quarter
mile comes with carbon ceramic breaks by
by default it has a stealth package 520
miles of range and will have all the
same advantages I just talked about in
luxury it's basically the Plaid plus
that never came out that Tesla never
made but guess what it's 250 000 so you
know this is a new company they haven't
made a lot of cars yet but what they're
doing is starting at their most
expensive highest margin versions of the
cars and then working their way down I
wouldn't be surprised if the Sapphire
version came out long before the Lucid
air pure which is the rear-wheel drive
base model for 87 000 comes out someday
in the future but that's their strategy
and that's so far made a pretty sweet
car
but when you only tackle Tesla's top
trims
might be trending towards trouble
thanks for watching
catch you guys in the next one peace